you brought up a very important point
because financial problems do lead to
conflict whether external or internal
you look at historically a lot of
economic upheaval was right before there
was a major fight that happened so
that's another aspect to kind of look at
here but this uh barbara f walter this
cia political scientist also said that
it's the erosion of democracy that
brings us closer to civil war and she
says that we're in between a democracy
and a uh autocracy anocracy democracy
and she specifically talked about how
there's a big separation within the
military how three former retired
military generals are talking about how
there's a major split in there and how
there could be a potential coup d'etat
or civil war within the military that
could make this into an actual hot water
let's pull this up we got the story from
the washington post
three retired retired generals the
military must prepare now for a 2024
insurrection
this is paul d eaton a retired us army
major general and senior adviser to vote
vets antonio m taguba retired army major
general general with 34 years of active
duty service stephen m anderson is
retired brigadier general who served in
the us army for 31 years now i want to
read a little bit what they say
but i want to i want to point
out we had the boston globe reporting
uh just before around around the
election time this past this last year
that john podesta
said that he had he or he was advising
the west coast to secede from the union
if donald trump wins
i think we may have just bought some
time
i think i think these next few years i
think a lot of people just didn't like
donald trump and they said oh okay 100
percent republican they were biased
i mean
what i mean is republicans aren't going
to be the ones to secede they're not the
fervent ideologues yeah that the left is
the left goes and smashes and destroys
and burns things down the moment you get
one day of one you know bad riot they
act like the apocalypse is happening and
that's what they're doing right now
right so what the washington what these
generals are saying is like oh no i
can't believe on january 6th the 7th
they say january 6 a disturbing number
of veterans that's right and active duty
members what they're basically saying is
the military is split and what happens
come 2024 when election happens it gets
disputed again and then
half the military says this side's right
the other half says this side's right yo
welcome to a civil war and i'll i'll
i'll accentuate this
five states right now are refusing
vaccine mandates and being told by the
the federalized you know the generals
running the national guard the federal
level or the you know the obama
administration you have to do this or
else and they're like nope national
guard state
so we're watching this this this
fracture already five states do you know
so i i know texas oklahoma let me
let me pull it up
five uh states national guard
that's crazy though yeah like it's gonna
be a standoff between those that are
vaccinated that aren't yeah i mean
there's so many things in play here man
we can even add in the fact that like
the family unit in the united states in
general is crumbling you know divorce
rates are at the highest have ever been
you know there's more single people
before it's five more states so it's
oklahoma so here we go we got oklahoma
wyoming iowa alaska nebraska and
mississippi and now texas
i was going to add to your point i don't
think it's going to be the vaxxers
versus the anti-vaxxers i think it's
going to be the double vaxxers versus
the quadruple
jillion
that the civil war is going to be
happening from my perspective yeah
there's going to be like bill maher
right yeah bill maher got he got the the
full dose at the time it was a full dose
now i guess it's not but he got two
shots so it's going to be the bill maher
people being like we already got
vaccinated we're not doing it again and
it's going to be the the the mega
vaxxers who are on their like 18th shot
because it's been you know a couple
years and they're going to be like
you're not up to date
i mean and the rest of the issue with
the vaccine man is that typically you
need at least what a decade to perfect
you know all these other vaccines that
we have in place for all these other
diseases you know they were
worked on and formulated and perfected
within a decade you know at bare minimum
you got this thing in a year well which
is why they got to keep punching
i will counter by saying mrna the the
the the precur like the beginnings of it
was in the 80s but not specifically for
covid now here's my here's my big thing
right i don't i i don't know how to
argue
scientific research you know what i mean
like none of us work in a lab none of us
can know for sure so i always i always
follow i'm saying like all the other vex
most of your other vaccines were like
you know perfected within a decade
whereas like on this one we did it in a
year different technologies it's like
but but it leads to a lot of people
saying they want long-term data on it
but i don't want to rehash that because
i'm trying to you know we'll keep it
focused yeah sure but the divide here is
real because there's some people in the
military saying i will comply with
biden's mandates some people saying they
won't comply that's already one divide
that's that doesn't even include the
political divide the social divide the
economical religious two as well the
religious divide i think they're just
literally making concepts and ideas up
about human beings to see how further
they could divide people because at the
end of the day i do believe a lot of
this kind of is divide and conquer i do
believe a lot of this is centralized but
the the the national guards in other
states saying hey we're not going to go
along with what you want us to do with
our own bodies is big and a sign of this
kind of civil uh conflict that we're
seeing the cia lady talk about for sure
i think there's an agenda being pushed
here and uh the more they can divide us
and see how we you know manage between
ourselves and we destroy ourselves the
better for them because they want to
conquer and overall having a one power
one i want to say one source you say yes
or no to if you comply or goodbye that's
cool so who is who's doing it who's
trying to divide us is it china
honestly well there's fourth
generational warfare there's fifth
generational warfare there's a lot of
other multinational corporations yeah
and some people would argue it is china
some people would argue it's the
multinational corporations that made
china as prominent as they are that sent
the slave jobs there that are connected
to the true billionaire class that's
connected to the banking class so
there's a lot of very powerful
institutions very powerful people but
then you get into the realms of
speculation i don't want to get into
into speculating here uh because we
could go on days and talk about
personally believe but i think it is
clear that we are being divided more
than we ever have been and it's turning
in a nasty nasty way that we have to try
to stop at all cost but it's not
stopping it's only let's say this with
china is that there's you know we're
talking about the civil war a war with
china is extremely probable you know
what i mean like china is
buying at the chop you know what i'm
saying they're buying at the bit right
now to go after taiwan they go after
taiwan well taiwan for a lot of you guys
that no i'm sure you know this they make
a bunch of our chips that are used for
technology and if china was to take over
taiwan that would put us in a very
difficult position where we would
probably have to come in and act and
defend and help taiwan and it's like uh
you know and that would put us in a
pretty bad spot because you don't want
to go to war with china they're our
biggest trader and already they're
talking about building a chip plant in
texas i believe yes because they're
trying to
there's no doubt about it they've been
waiting for for years to do it here
here's the here's the issue i take with
uh with like this you know they're
trying to divide us i'm just like trying
to figure out who is they because when
you've got the military split when
you've got thirty thousand active duty
military saying no to the vaccines when
seven states are saying they will not
abide by this for the national guard and
i'm like is it is it the the
establishment like is it the democrats
the uniparty and now there's like a
populist wave that's rejecting this
because if that's the case then the
division is natural it's populist versus
elitist or is there a larger
international group like luke mentions
like multinational corporations who are
pitting populists and helping fund these
campaigns to create division in the us
or is it is it actually just that there
is a a psychotic cult ideology growing
in this country that manifests itself in
in violence and ignorance and then there
are regular people who are trying to
make you know trying to live trying to
get by and when you try you know you
know and and i'll accept some of the
criticism in this regard because it's
frustrating to me when i try over and
over again to reach an olive branch out
to these people and what do we get we
got what happened here last week anger
rage on both sides to be fair but if i'm
like okay i'll give you that point i'll
give you that point i'll give you that
point will you agree with me on this and
they say no and they say screw you and
they they threaten more violence at a
certain point you know look we're we are
not the this is this show is not the
trump maga hat cue anything like that
this is the show where i'm talking to a
dude who's very lefty very woke and i'm
like i i agree with you on systemic
racism i agree with you on those issues
do you agree with me on individual
rights and they say no
if i keep giving olive branches out and
they keep taking and taking and taking
so i don't know if this isn't if this if
there's like an elite group trying to do
this on purpose or this is what happens
when you get a cult ideology that is
fervent angry and ignorant and you get
people who
are
i guess opposed to that and unwilling to
compromise with it is not respected
anymore independent thinking is no
longer respected it's like you can't
have an opinion on something it's like
oh you think
you think trump did a good job oh well
you're a bigot you know what i'm saying
they're immediately going to subscribe
you to to that end just because of their
personal feelings whereas like hey you
did it so let's do a terrible job
let me ask you real quick
people talk about all the time it might
be illuminati it might be bilderberg who
knows what it is right i'm just saying
when all the chaos comes order so look
like trojan horse right they get you
from the inside and uh inside out i'm
just saying like in terms of what we're
going around in the future like let's be
real here we're not getting any better
we're not again we're not coming
together as one we're dividing between
each other yeah but race you know
religion all this stuff why is this
happening there's somebody out there
pushing an agenda i don't know who it is
but it's causing divide and once that
happens at some point
just really quickly tim you you laid out
three hypotheses right
all of them could be through true at the
same time so we have to also entertain
those larger ideas and spectrum of
understanding here because it could be a
natural divide that some people are
playing off that of course also benefits
china as well so all three parameters
could be at play here and we could be
trying to figure out we shouldn't try to
pinpoint exactly
you know like this is exactly how it is
because it's almost impossible to figure
out there's a lot of disinformation
there's a lot of fake information that's
being deliberately released out there to
confuse people to make people go crazy
uh going down the rabbit hole we don't
have to go down the rabble we see the
problems we have to do everything we can
to prevent them because these problems
are getting real they're getting
dangerous and they're going to be have
significant ramifications for everyone's
life very soon if they already don't
here's here's the challenge because
because luke you sound a lot like ian
so you know ian he's on holiday shout
out ian um
he likes to say
you know we got to bring people together
man we can't allow this division and i'm
like that's right that proud boy wearing
the maga hat needs to throw down that
shield run up to the antifa guy the
antifa guy needs to take his mask off
pull down the hoodie they should run to
each other and embrace in a nice arm
lock and say we're in this together and
that'll happen right that's gonna is is
that is that gonna happen it sounds good
but it's never gonna happen unless it's
in a pepsi commercial unless it's a
pepsi commercial so this is what i'm
saying
we can invite these people on the show
they won't do it i i i sent her son
[ __ ] a message i was like hey man would
you like to come on the show we'd love
to have you you know we'll pay for
everything just no response dude doesn't
owe me a thing okay he doesn't have to
come on the show but if we can't get
people to come on the show to talk about
these things then how do you actually
even work towards mending that divide
and worse still when we invite someone
on the show who is very much into
wokeness and as he described it the
black struggle and i tell him i agree
with you on all of these points and then
he still calls me names he still insults
me he still laughs me and calls me a
liar and all stuff you know at a certain
point i'm watching these high-profile
individuals keep trying to compromise
and it doesn't work we are dealing with
zealotry whatever this side is you know
for us freedom independence liberty
you've got many conservatives involved
there is a live and let live classical
liberalism in there and somewhat
traditional liberalism and then in the
cult you have a shut up and do as you're
told or else
i don't know
what anyone can do at this point and i'm
sorry if it sounds pessimistic to
convince the maga hat wearing trump
supporter with the american flag to go
up to antifa and shake their hand and
say let's make this country a better
place because if even if that were to
happen the next step is antifa saying
okay let's tear down the american
institution let's burn the constitution
let's get rid of our court system and
the trump supporter guy is going to be
like but those are good things yeah yeah
just add to your point uh tim i don't
believe there's a way we can ourselves
can come together as one however maybe
through fair or through like a tragic
event it might bring us together i don't
know what it's going to be but us is
like you know either trump supporters or
like you know antifa us we're not going
to do it by ourselves it has to be
outside cause they make us come together
but i don't know what it's going to be
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time